[music]
>> I'm Terence Tao. I'm director of special
projects here at IPAM, the Institute for
Pure and Applied Mathematics. AI has
really been um improving very rapidly.
It has allowed me to experiment. I will
try crazier things. You can vibe on the
blackboard and then if there's a
computation that neither of us wants to
do, we can just get our AI tool to
finish that.
>> [music]
>> I can search literature much more
accurately and effectively than I could
before. So, I'm doing way more
AI-assisted mathematics and and
collaborative projects. And now I think
it's ready for prime time.
>> Fundamentally, at Open AI, we care about
being at the frontier in terms of
automating science, the economy, and
ourselves. We care less about winning a
Nobel Prize or a Fields Medal, and more
about enabling 100 mathematicians out
there to do that for themselves.
>> We lived in a world of cognitive
friction until very recently, where
every task required us to use our brain.
[music] And so, we didn't really think
about it. We just thought this was the
cost of doing something intellectual.
But now we have AI and the other
technologies that can bring these
frictions down to zero.
I hope when AI usage becomes more
commonplace, people will also post not
just the final product, but all the
different paths that they used to get
[music] there, cuz that's also very
useful information.
I think we can find some way to have the
best of both worlds.